jetzt kommt die tomaten krippe tomate
ich noch nie gehört dieses wort bis zum
heutigen tag das ist ein neues virus
ausgebrochen ist ein schön indien und
sie sehen sehr ansteckend die symptome
ähnlich wie bei corona aber eben sie
sehen hier anhand dieser bilder nicht
nur das also fieber müdigkeit
kopfschmerzen nein auch am ganzen körper
rote bläschen deshalb ja auch die
tomaten grippe ja das müssen wir uns mal
erklären lassen von unserem experten von
klaus stöhr virologe sie kennen herzlich
willkommen bei bild lei verstört also
hier geht es nicht um eine neue sau
durchs dorf treiben aber ein bisschen
hat es uns ausgestattet der name der
bleibt sofort wieder hängen dann sieht
es schon mal gehört und können sie ganz
schnell einmal erklären unseren
zuschauern was hat es auf sich mit der
tomaten krippe aus indien ja gehört hab
ich das auch nicht schön und tag erstmal
das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen so
eine fehlinformation die erkrankung
tatsächlich aufgetreten allerdings
krankheitsbild eigentlich bekannt von
einem virus das nennt man chikungunya
virus
weiter verbreitet durch moskitos
zirkuliert aber auch zwischen menschen
und das ist in der stadt kommt nicht nur
in indien vor das kommt einer
gesetzlichen fast die gesamte
südhalbkugel vor wird durch musik wird
hauptsächlich übertragen und das kann
bei 50 prozent der kinder auch unter
fünf jahren so eine ausschlag
hervorrufen gerade weil ausbrüchen wenn
da viele kinder gleichzeitig betroffen
sind und wir gehen eigentlich davon aus
das ist wahrscheinlich das virus ist die
sich schick und grüne erkrankung die
wada sähen das ist kein neues tomaten
virus hat auch nicht mit influenza und
fluss betont also man muss das
beobachten wissenschaftlich interessant
das schreckt natürlich viele auf aber
das wird höchstwahrscheinlich in wenigen
tagen nicht ausstellen als entweder
schick und cunha gibt auch andere
hämorrhagische fieber die so eine
klinische symptomatik hervorrufen das
muss also beobachten aber ich glaube
nicht dass es sich hier zu irgendwas
dramatisch entwickeln wird das sind doch
mal gute nachrichten denn die verkünde
ich hier wir hier besonders gerne mal
bei bild live also vermutlich etwas das
es schon lange gibt können sie uns hier
ein warnung erteilen müssen wir es nicht
fürchten jetzt kommt der nächste mission
eingeräumt ist müssen wir wieder nochmal
masken darüber war ihr urteil sprechen
nochmal alles wieder aufgeräumt jetzt
tomate oder egal wie wir es nennen
entwarnung jetzt von ihnen hier bei uns
ja also für leute die geologie biologie
lieben dass der dollar anfang mai ist
virus neue forschung neue erkenntnis
aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass ist
wirklich schick und gunnar ist dieses
durch moskitos übertragene virus das
zuerst
diva hervorruft grippeähnliche symptome
wie viele virus infekte und zu anfang
man dann in der zweiten phase war nur
schwere gelenkschmerzen und in der
nächsten phase dann diese lesen haus aus
schlaf beim großteil der kinder also ich
gehe mal davon aus dass der hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit die nachricht dass es
ein neues virus sein soll stimmt nicht
man mussten wir uns erst mal finden dann
muss man das testen dann muss man das
neu an züchten dann muss man die
krankheit noch mal reproduzieren das ist
also relativ langer prozess nur neues zu
entdecken wir haben das er gemacht 2003
mit dem das virus in einem globalen team
das hat immerhin vier wochen gedauert
war zwar auch ein weltrekord zu dem
zeitpunkt aber hier würde ich glauben
handelt nicht um eine interessante
nachricht aber für uns in europa spielt
das keine rolle wie gesagt die mücken
die diese erkrankungen übertragen kommen
bei uns auch nicht nur einzelne fälle in
spanien
ansonsten blieb das duo hauptsächlich
auf der südhalbkugel kleider dabei die
moskitos eben auch
er mücken kommen leider sehr viel vor in
deutschland wie seit heute nacht wieder
weiß aber diese mücken nicht sagt klaus
stört dass die gute nachricht